foreign
mustache and Corvette music not really
Corvette it's Camaro music
it's facts of your friends time let's do
it
[Music]
music
Kelly's just gonna uh
this goes so good with your dragon
tattoos just the music just feels like a
dragon tattoo and that if Karate Kid
seven came out all right so um Kelly
gave me these two articles one of the
things I want to do uh that we've begun
doing on facts your friends is taking
things that are non-pathological meaning
they're not in the DSM they are not you
wouldn't go to a doctor and get
diagnosed with this but that it's made
its way into the vernacular it's
something that is just made its way into
the world and we hear it all the time
um like I've got overachieving anxiety
no you don't because that's not a thing
it's not real it's not a thing
um so
today she handed me this and there's
it's called hurry sickness hurry
sickness
um or constant panic and Rush is another
way they say it but tell me if this
sounds familiar
um this uh I don't even see an author
here it's just written by mindtools.com
tell me if this sounds familiar
you rush into work late again after
doing the school run and navigating
through traffic
when you open up your computer there are
so many email and message notifications
that you don't even know where to start
then you realize you're late for a
meeting so you rush off half Walking
Half running and you grab a seat in the
meeting room
a few minutes later you realize that
you're double booked and you make your
apologies and dash off to join a
conference call you're late to the
conference call
your day ahead looks just as hectic so
while you're on the phone you reply to
emails marked urgent check your calendar
and reply to several messages and
there's no let up even after you arrive
home you somehow juggle cooking a meal
putting the kids to bed doing some
housework while preparing for a
presentation that you're giving in the
morning and then when you finally get to
bed your mind is still racing worrying
about all the things you still haven't
been able to get get around to and we'll
have to tackle tomorrow
does this frantic sense of always being
on the go seem familiar people with
hurry sickness think fast talk fast they
act fast they're always going from thing
to thing to thing to thing to thing
um I
I
didn't know the phrase hurry hurry
sickness I hadn't heard that before but
there is this sense
um
that this is the age we're in
and we've it it's been roundly debunked
in scientific studies this idea of
um multitasking it's not real it's
impossible your brain can't do it so
when you are listening to your kid
checking your email also has have the
radio going and you're watching a TV
show in the background
and your husband's explaining something
to you your brain is not can't absorb
all of that at one time and makes sense
of it it's just toggling back and forth
and so you're getting pieces of
different information you're getting
pieces of experiences all at the same
time and so it's you're not ever
anywhere
that's been the biggest like Revelation
like
I'm not really anywhere ever
and I end up driving my car 500 miles an
hour to work uh I I have to I'm running
out the door I'm speeding to work or I'm
frustrated I'm late to this first
meeting and because I'm late to the
first meeting I'm gonna be late to every
other meeting and then somebody stops me
and they're like hey I'm hurting like my
mom just passed away and I want to stop
and talk but I've created a schedule for
myself I've got no margin then I feel
guilty and it just never stops
and then I take that energy and I look
at my kids and that energy is like a a
laser and it melts them they can't
handle that much Focus
what do you need and I hear my
six-year-old my seven-year-old she's
just stumbling through the word she's
like um I uh I I'm like what do what hon
what do you need right and then they get
it too
hurry sickness
so you can't go to the doctor they're
not going to diagnose you with hurry
sickness
um the more I dug into the research and
where I just landed on my book is this
I don't know
um you've heard me say anxiety is an
addiction you get addicted to it what I
don't know is
um if you have links to studies and you
put on the show in the comments that
would be awesome
um what I don't know is do you actually
get chemically addicted like you would
to Opium or to heroin or alcohol do you
get addicted to the cortisol and
adrenaline because when you are running
that fast when you're driving 95 miles
down the down the road your body is
amped up and when you're going from
meeting to meeting and you're running
down the hallway and you go in and
you're kind of catching your breath over
your coffee and then you realize oh I'm
supposed to be another meeting your body
is keeping the score as Vandercook says
it's running and running and running and
running so I don't know if you actually
get addicted to the cortisol and
adrenaline
to the
um to the hormones and the
neurotransmitters and the
neuromodulators I don't know if you get
addicted to them as chemicals or your
body gets addicted to your Downstream
response to those things the the drink
you you drink to take the edge off the
numbing you do in front of Netflix the
Mindless sex or pornography consumption
the
um that you go smoke a joint just to
chill out or you take a bunch of gummies
just to chill
I don't know
but Judd Brewer's work on anxiety is
Excellence it's just it's a it's a habit
and response mechanism
and ultimately if your body can spin you
up
it can get What It Wants Downstream
which is another drink so here's the
here's my point I don't know I think
it's fair to call anxiety and addiction
I will continue to call it but I don't
know if it's a downstream addiction like
you're addicted to the food that you eat
when you're stressed or if you're
actually addicted to the the chemicals
in your body that are pulsed into your
body either way it doesn't matter
hurry sickness is because it's become a
way of being we've created anxious lives
for ourselves that quite frankly our
bodies can't exist in and they are
coming apart at the seams look around
okay so
um and we'll link to these in the show
notes these are their pop psychology
right they're just
um uh it's
not a lot of like neuroscience and
things like that if you want great
Neuroscience there's other places you
can go on the internet but
um I think it is worth reading because
they they just
they just kind of call out our life the
way we're choosing to live
um here's a couple of things you can do
here
um made some notes Here let me see we're
like oh number one
um know this
flying around the world is making things
worse so stop
[Music]
stop
this was the big Revelation for me
not that I had to figure out what new
planner was going to help me toggle all
this or what new apps were going to help
me talk that's the last 10 years if you
just get the right planner you just do
all this in yoga or and you know
mindfulness training you're cool or if
you just get these apps they'll help
organize you
um my friend Joshua burns with the
minimalist says that uh organizing is
just well thought out hoarding right and
you can hoard with stuff or you can
hoard with activities or you can hoard
with thoughts that never stop right
so
I have to know out the gate this is
killing me
it's making me very hard to be in
relationship with is is not helping my
work performance it's not helping my
parenting or marriage performance it's
not helping my engagement with my
community it's not helping other people
in my life feel loved so stop
that's number one
okay underneath that number two
I have to learn how to be clear about
what I need
about boundaries I can't do that I have
to learn how to say no
to my kids
I want to play soccer and I want to do
ballet and Mom can I get a horse
you can do one thing
you get to choose you get to do one
um I have to say no and the boss says
hey can you take on this other thing too
I have to say
no man I I I'm maxed right now if you
can give me one week I'll have created
some space and I can take that on
but just saying yeah you got it and then
being pissed off that your boss came to
you for it
then being pissed off that you have no
more time being pissed so here's a good
example I agreed to a book deadline on
January 15th I agreed to it
I said I'll have it done
my birthday weekend was spinning a hotel
writing
not my friends and family it was spent
Christmas Eve I turned in a chapter
Christmas Day after we opened up
presents and everyone's gonna on a sugar
rush and we I did some more writing
and I can be mad at the the publishing
arm uh my publisher I can be mad at my
dude I chose this
I agreed to it all
so I have to get clear about my needs I
need to spend time with my family on
Christmas I need to have my birthday
weekend so I can celebrate that with my
kids and my wife and my friends
here's what I need here are my
boundaries I've got to say those things
out loud and I have had to learn over
time how to do it and I still I could
just mention I still stumble still fall
right number three here is a practical
thing never speed only drive the speed
limit
which if you ride with me you know that
you're like I think you're insane
Kelly's like I'm gonna call bullcrap on
that one on a stick
um
if you just for 30 days I got this from
John Mark Comer if you just for 30 days
to Sam's gonna drive speed limit
number one I did it and it was super
annoying here's why it was annoying I
had to leave earlier which meant I had
to plan which meant I couldn't just sit
and scroll mindlessly or read mindlessly
or whatever sometimes my son had to go
to school not looking like I would have
loved because I gotta leave and I'm not
speeding number two and this really
pissed me off I showed up to work
infinitely less stressed
I was pretty chill
and I thought oh you got me
because I fly down the road at 95 miles
an hour and then I fly into work and
then I fly into the meeting and
everyone's like whoa
and then I get mad that they're frazzled
it's on me so just decide for 30 days
I'm just gonna drive a speed limit
everywhere and you're gonna get run over
on the road you're gonna have to go to
the another Lane you may have to use
cruise control to practice just try it
for 30 days driving the speed limit and
you'll get stressed at first because
everyone's driving past and then settle
into it
put your phone away number four put your
phone away put your phone away put your
phone away it is adding noise and Chaos
in spaces that normally throughout all
of human history gave us pause times
between work times between action times
when we were waiting times when we were
outside times between human interactions
now we just have that phone and we're
shoving every Square centimeter of our
lives with space and noise and flashy
things and red alerts put it away
put it away
um last one and this is um something I'm
starting effective immediately
is a radical sense an unerant radical
sense
I will be on time everywhere
I'm gonna be on time starting now
Kelly's like ah
I call bullcrap in a box on a stick on
top of a building
with a parachute and dragon wings
be radically on time just don't be late
try for 30 days I'm gonna try it I'll
try we have a we have a jar that we just
keep on the desk here for when I was
late or not and I'll just donate it to
charity whatever's left we should just
do that
remember the whole there was a one point
in time you were going to give me like
five dollars every time you said
something and we got up to like 100
something dollars I still haven't seen
that either so here we go here we go
oh it's just and I would also like to
point out that you didn't start the not
be late thing today
no I'm starting Anew today okay because
we were we were late starting today I
just said starting now
unbelievable
hmm
guess you're right it is unbelievable
you may need to get a new boss too or
work somewhere else
#just saying hurry sickness here's the
deal
look at your life in your calendar and
look for this one precious thing space
margin a gap in your calendar
and if you don't have it find it if you
don't have it let your needs be heard
and yes I hear you single moms with
three kids or single dads and you're
like dude I don't have to I get it
you're in a season I get it I get it I
get it
this might be something that you work
towards over time
but hurry sickness is drowning you it's
not a real thing but
an anxious lifestyle
an anxious world is burning a hole
through you and those you love
stop
and try to build something different